hello and welcome to this video
another blitz game here it's three
minutes
and i got e4 here what is the latest
word on that
i totally forgot
i think it's bishop before
and then a quick bishop c5
abu yaha 1983 is my opponent
it's three minute chess that's uh i have
to absolutely
get that into my head
i don't know maybe i should really go
for five zero for the games here on the
channel and
and accept that it takes longer to get
the games it really takes a lot longer
that seems to be the least popular time
controlled somehow
yeah maybe f4 is this idea
take player 4 it's probably a good
pragmatic approach
so yeah i would like to go f5
to fight against the center but not with
the bishop on g4
so f5 next is my idea
he probably wants to answer that with e5
maybe i'm a little bit worried that
my bishop while looking good on c5 it's
not doing anything
and maybe gets pushed away by b4 this is
why i'm playing
the bishop to c3 that i'm ready to take
so let's go f5
that kind of a new account or something
no it's not a new account
so take here
yeah i have to be alert that
for tactics for possible discoveries
maybe remove this
like discoveries with the bishop here
somewhere on that rook on evade
i know i i complete i forgot to take
i'm a clown now that made no sense
whatsoever
ah shoot
i completely completely forgot
to complete my original idea
bishop g5 or something i can take okay
so here yeah i have to take this
it's just nothing else
it's pretty pretty equal
maybe white has a
minimal pole but
i am probably not
no that's just nothing going on
how does he cover that here maybe
queen to d8 is that a problem
if i take this
what is the thing is i mean he probably
has some kind of a
draw okay
queen d8 yeah it's probably just a draw
right
check i can take with the bishop though
it's still going to be
nothing
okay this is just a check though right
so i can take on g2
and go back
now he can he cannot mate me because he
has no
control um on the light squares at all
[Music]
oh no oh that is a session from hell
i miss that simple move
now because i was somewhat shocked i
will lose this crap on time
position is totally dead of course
yeah okay that's totally nonsense
yeah okay you don't even need to analyze
this game completely pointless
yeah it was just like completely um
nothing going on
the whole time and then i'm doing
something totally stupid
and i should just take on c3 before
something bad happens like here
just take it i mean
i was lucky that i didn't drop anything
if i just take here it's just totally
equal just nothing happening
and this i was just missing it seems
that the computer doesn't see anything
too terrible it's it
it's a bit of a scare this actually
would have scared me
queen to d7 is the only move here
wow yeah i mean if i take here there are
checks now that's a problem well
like this this for this of course um
okay but queen d7 does hold
even though that looks scary
yeah at the end of the day this is
hanging and you cannot mate me yet it
just doesn't work
something like this there's also a mate
here
yeah it would have been still very scary
and here this is just a dead position
more or less but i managed to uh
to miss that one move and that that
costs too much time
i just cost too much time the engine
gives me an advantage here but this is
some
it's just it's just totally totally
drawn drawish
[Music]
yeah and that is the only move but i was
so shocked it took me eight seconds
and that eight seconds were too much
to get this uh anywhere near uh
a full draw i don't even need to blunder
that pawn but okay it's not about the
position
yeah but here it's just a complete
fortress also
yeah i don't know 3-0 is probably not
right yeah for those videos
and i also don't want to lose every game
because
um the combined commentary
and playing is so
damaging maybe five zero is the way to
go
or three plus two and i have to adjust
in the other games
it's a bit difficult sometimes to switch
around with the time controls um
at least that's what i feel now after
having
restarted the videos okay
guys not a good game and not a good day
and still
thanks for watching